[music]
welcome,
ladies and gentlemen, at home on the
screen and here in the berlin
natural history museum
i don't know if you
can see it at home we are here in the midst of
magnificent forest dwellers we are
in the so-called bird room of the
natural history museum and all around  we have
parrots here at a safe distance
from me there is a jaguar if i
see it correctly or yes a jaguar
that fishes a parrot out of the trees so i think we have the
right attitude
to talk about biodiversity today about forests
forest conversion climate change and what the
research in berlin and brandenburg
has to do with it
the topic of climate change and forest was
also a political topic this week
and i would like to read you a short
sentence from a report that
the scientific advisory board for
forest policy in the
federal
ministry of agriculture published this week it
says  the rapidly advancing
climate  change accelerates the erosion of the
relevance of previous empirical knowledge
and leads to an increase in
uncertainties erosion of
empirical knowledge increase in
uncertainties this is something that the
internships and practitioners of the forests
have to do with and also the
research that has to do with the forest
we  we are here today for the third
climate lab of the climate change center
berlin-brandenburg and i want
to briefly remind you
what this small climate change
center berlin brandenburg actually is it is
a network of universities and
research institutes in berlin and
brandenburg
they are part of it  the free university
the tu berlin the charité the
university of the arts the university of potsdam
and the potsdam institute for
climate impact research i think almost
everyone is represented here today with
contributions among other things we also have
an arc on medicine charité and on
the arts that will be exciting
you are  here today too  asked above
all you who are sitting in front of the screen
to participate
we have a participation tools lite it's
called and while
i'm warming up a bit
you can log in there you can
take part in a quiz right away and that  goes when
you call up www.eito.com and then you
need a code and i can see it is
also displayed the code is
hashtag 87 6 305 hashtag 87 63 05 so and
now you might be wondering
who this guy is actually
in front my name is carel mohn i
am the editor-in-chief of klima fakten de
and i will guide you through the
program today yes i already said
we will talk about the forest
and the topic of climate change today and
maybe quite fitting to my
role at klima fakten de  if you have
discussions, you should have a
certain factual basis and how it is
with your personal
factual basis  ns
let’s take a look and we’ll just start
with this forest quiz as a relaxed introduction
by the way, it was developed by
tamina scheinig who should actually
be sitting here on the stage right away
she is a forest pedagogue at the
German Forest Protection Association
but is unfortunately ill anyway thanks
to mrs your honey  for help with the
work this quiz yes and i'll start
the quiz with a simple
question
think of the forest think of
germany and the question for you is
how much area in germany is covered with
forest
we have three possible answers a
quarter  a third or half
and you can now click and i
let the technology tell me
we are here in a hybrid
event so real people are sitting here in
front of me and i am
also happy that this third
life is at least partly a real
event  but there is such a
time lag that is when you take the
quiz  it's a bit
later in your real life at
home than in real life
here so we're taking a little
time but i see the results are
trickling in and
i don't know if it's still going or if
we're done my it's still going
it's going to be super exciting yes and
now a bar will turn green the
correct answer is a third
a clear majority also knew that and
yes germany is
not the very biggest country in the eu, but it's not the smallest either
i think we're
number five  or six of the area in
europe or 7 and we belong to the
densely forested countries in europe so and
now we come to biology or
plant physiology and
the next question namely why does
the tree lose
its leaves in autumn four possible answers
a otherwise it would freeze
to death  would otherwise dry out and c he
would otherwise starve so three possible
answers as the first
time
I can yes ni  let's see if my audience
here knows that too, but
it's well stocked with experts
so let's assume that
the answer is known here,
so why do the trees lose their
leaves in
autumn may have something to do with our climate
war zone
because in the
tropics are not seasonal
and the correct answer is that
otherwise they would dry out and
[music]
35 percent of
the audience
knew that and i want to tell you
why is it like that when the ground
cools down in winter in autumn  the
roots have less and less water on and
near the freezing point the
water absorption is then completely stopped and
since the leaves evaporate water
and if this continued in winter
the tree would finally dry out
and by shedding the leaves
the forest protects itself from
drying out like that  and the next question in
our quiz how much oxygen
does a 100 year old
average person produce  here tree per year so
oxygen production per year about 200
kilos
4000 kilos so four tons or
16000 16 tons of oxygen it is
hard to imagine
but you can still click
and yes there is even enough time
that you can
look it up in wikipedia
then you just have to know which
article it is in and you have to be able to
read it
quickly faster than i’m
going to tell you the answer in a moment i’ll tell you that
a person consumes or
needs around 15 to two kilos of
oxygen a day
and yes, have the right answer
here again you know with a clear
relative majority of 48% four
tons of oxygen is produced by an approximately
100 year old tree in germany
maybe we’ll get to that how
does climate change
change that so i think that was the
first part of our quiz the second  come
later now we want to and that
is one of the basic ideas of this
gem lab  take a look at the
research practice in berlin and
brandenburg, we have an
incredibly exciting
research landscape here in the region
and one that has been dealing with forest research for centuries and one of the people who is
researching in the middle
of this world is manfred
faust reuter  biologist and
private lecturer at the fu berlin and he
heads the research project climate forest
at the free university this project is
running in grunewald and if you want to put it very
simply then it's
about finding the common beech with the ideal
drought or heat that can
also be found in a climate  changed world
in the local forests everything that is spread out grows
well you can present the project
and I will give you this microphone for
it yes thank
you very much ladies and gentlemen I am particularly
happy
to present the climate forest project here at the s1 like herbs climate forest project that  is
a research area that we in
cooperation with m  With the Berlin forests and
the
forest museum we have set up the German Forest Protection Association in
Grunewald and there we work with
beech trees from all over Europe.
The beech tree is our most important tree for
biodiversity for the eel deposit
you also know that the tree of the year
2020, the common beech, is an
important point and i would like to
briefly present the project to you.
i have brought you a video where you
can see these climate forest research areas
in berlin at the grunewald about 4000
square meters where we 45 origins from
have planted all of europe large
trees that we planted there
but also small trees on the far right you can
see trees from
sicily phenotypically different than on the left trees from
brandenburg we would like to rate these trees of
course they are typical but of
course you also know that
phenotypically geno has typical
characteristics we want  wi  eat like these plants
with climate stress that also prevails in the grunewald
extreme stress comes about
we want at the same time and southern
sweden with celebrities from
sicily different ways of adapting on
this research area we have
installed an irrigation system we
can irrigate different trees or
small and large trees with different intensity
and under stress, of
course, we also plant new
trees there and you are also welcome to take on
a sponsorship and here we are
just planting a red beech from the
goal was together with robert metcalfe
a songwriter something more
about this project
on this area  frost
applies just as much as heat and extreme
drought and we want to
find out and
test
that by
planting leaves how do we deal with the difference here origin here you can now see individual plantings that
we have set up in grunewald about 4000
square meters that i had ih  n mentions
where each individual tree has
to establish itself first it
takes a certain amount of time we have built up
the synchronous forest with many helpers
and now i will show you what
we want to do scientifically a
cooperation with colleague
syrien heese where we data from the holidays exploration
and geoinformation  want to display
and we present the climatic forest 3d moderately
because i want to show you that now in this
short video we
define this forest and create 3d
point clouds from the forest
from the climatic forest you can see that it resembles
you yes i was completely surprised we
have a resolution of 1  .2 centimeters
we can represent each individual tree from these
samples your train or i just
heard from sicily from etna or tommy
pro the nation of tobacco or southern sweden
and we can play there
i told you that for an
irrigation system we have we
can zoom in there  in every single tree yes
what we want to do in the future
w  we want to put these trees under stress
and then it's like that we
cheated with the remote sensing and that's the
same in them that we represent the vitality of these
trees so we can
zoom in
we have excellent possibilities we of course also want to
make measurements red based and they
see now here with infrared
recordings we can show the vitality of the
trees so we could now if
we irrigate different areas or
let them dry out sub-areas describe
what we have now managed to build up
the vitality of these trees
and that's what we want to do in the future
the next point i would like to have
You are now spontaneously inviting us to the climate forest song with Robert Metcalfe and
perhaps a large choir tomorrow morning no
tomorrow noon on November 6th if you
feel like coming to the grunewald on the
Berlin forestry site you will get
an impression of what we are doing and
we hope for one  chorus
[music]
follow wac  hsen
no
[music]
because
so i thank you for your attention
thank you and hope that you will be there
tomorrow thank you
yes i think that's great we are so
interactive that tomorrow it will continue in a
real forest and the art
is also part of it thank you
very much mr forstreuter  on the climate forest project and
now we are looking a little
closer to individual trees and
i would like to say let's welcome a little bit from the
barc project
bank project park the bark is the bark the
component of the trees it plays
the music in the life of the trees
but when  if you then look at the wood
and how it is used, burke and
cattle is actually something almost just a
waste product that is ground up
and pressed into pellets and frau
little is a material researcher and
product designer and she
deals with the question does it have
to be like this and  ca
n't you make something great, beautiful, more lively out of the bark of the bark
and lady little you
can  I would like to introduce that now,
good evening,
thank you very much for the great
introduction, I can actually get started right away,
so today I will show you a little
insight into my doctoral thesis, I
have different mistakes in it, but
today I chose one that you can
also use in  the exhibition
that runs next door can also look at
exactly the band project it's about what
else can we actually do with tree bark in our local wants then
as already said at the introduction
ultimately raw material wood this
raises the question of how sustainable
our wood production actually is and
if  we take a closer look so we see
that there are
quite a lot of by-products,
including the tree bark in short numbers
to say about ten to 20 each construction
fair are bark so
around four million cubic
meters of tree bark are produced as waste material in
germany every year and my idea was
how  can we have the beef  using it differently
one point that was also very
important to me was watching how we can use
the bark in its entirety longer
because ultimately when he looks at his tree
we have
materials that can be up to eleven
meters long or a lot
together with colleagues
i then peeled bark from the
brandenburg forest for a longer period of time
you could say yes you can do that
with cork, for example,
but in the Mediterranean climate cork oak ultimately grows
with our pine bark,
which we used for this here
on the left  the picture is that of a
larch nothing else has been done
exactly so as you can see we played the
bark then we dried the bark
and the problem was while
we were sending it because it was
really nice and flexible it was like
a carpet  That's right
, the hard work
makes it very brittle and
se  hr brittle you can
imagine it like why a
crispbread that just breaks so quickly
and we wanted to maintain this
flexibility and a method
that you know from the blood
conversation from the
preparation is ultimately
to use pizzerias and water so with
glycerine solution that then keeps a certain part
of the water in the bark and
that made it possible for us
to produce a material that is then so
flexible and also remains so flexible
that feels a bit different
is of course a shame for the
spectators now  on the
screen it feels a
bit like between wood and leather
and there it starts a bit like wood
and leather and
after a while you get weird in your doctoral thesis
i then asked myself what
it would be like if i were a tree
bark  what is it like when you use tree bark
as a substitute for leather jackets, for example
, then we have di  ese jackets
developed together with my colleague
johanna here and who chose them
great the problem is only the
bark is not as stretchy as leather which
means that our model cannot live the arms
so this is a
very limited pose that was possible
here  but if you
look at materials such as
cotton fibers, for example, then this is not
the way we make it,
a textile like we weave it
that ultimately makes it the war that means
we thought about how we could do that
, different fibers are
cut  by hand with picking and
then went to a loom
and then developed jackets from it where
the bark is ultimately
flexible, yes, this model can
raise your arms, but in the
end it is actually
a big material, i've already
told myself we've got until  played eleven meters in a
row so we thought about
how we could ensure that more
people in r  duck and we have
developed a walk-in object
the pension sphere and i would
like to invite you to our institute where
you can enter the sphere and
then experience what it
would ultimately be like to be in tree bark, also as an idea
for temporary architecture
for farr pavilions for tents that can then be developed from
local pine cattle
and with that i
would finally like to thank everyone who
helped me and wish you fun with the
further program
thank you very much mrs little i hope that
next time i will be the moderator with
so  a rain
jacket would also
fit in with the family history my
great-grandfather still had a
loom in the living room in bernau many
thanks the bank project is also an
exciting website we come from the
bark to the part of the trees that
classically and are the first thing that comes to
mind when you arrive  the use of
trees thinks wood wood for building
and for that  r let's now take a look at
the natural building lab at the
technical university of berlin this
building lab is managed and brought to
life by professor eicke
roßwag klinge and it's about built
prototypes for a post-fossil age
it's about circular building systems that
use of renewable raw materials
but also of railway or reused
building materials so the question is
how can you process wood that has already been
used, for example in
roof trusses, so that the
co2 stored in it, which is great
in times of climate change, is not
burned but instead
can be used again for building and out says
klinger please you can introduce yours live
thank you
i am happy that i am allowed to represent the
mmi of the forest of course or nature for
the building the network
building lab is a transdisciplinary
laboratory which in the real context in  the city
leap innovations to building makes the
g  gets a lot of questions that
i can't answer all of them just very
briefly what is it building we know that
all
students are building and the elephant in the
climate room we are responsible for 40 percent of the
energy consumption and also want to remove
30 percent of the materials that  we have to
build if we
add the cloudy excavation from the construction sites, that's
about 60 percent of the materials that we
move, so 60 percent of the waste are
quasi
resources of the building, so we're looking for
something after this fossil
age that's no longer on concrete,
steel, glass  familiar we are looking for
something that will overcome modernity and that
we all can't really
imagine yet with a look speaks of
factor 10 that's what we have as a
task for society we
have to reduce our consumption to ten
percent and you won't do that
can do with increases in efficiency alone this study is wonderful it
cool study by the federal environment agency  s next to
the energy question we have to
save 90 percent 95 percent of the co2 gases on the
left diagram on the left
, but above all we have to reduce 60 percent of the material withdrawals by 2050 in order to
achieve a resource-fair
planetary life, so to
speak
, that means we
actually have  no more material to
build and we have to start the construction that means
the agricultural turnaround with the market value
heat turnaround industry walls and above
all the construction turnaround and
there is the coupling of forest and building
the use of wood or in the future
from the alcohol industry  so
natural fibers we will get such a battery
agriculture where we couple trees with
the agricultural land and there
we will find substances that can guide us in the
future but
above all we have to change our entire way of thinking
we have to
reduce this review from first of course
land consumption of the Federal Environment Agency
says we have to live at least  at least
20 percent down from the now almost
50 to 40 square meters per capita that we
naturally pull the work straight that
means we theoretically thought 2050
20 percent vacancy because we do
not expect any growth in the population in europe
in the next 80 years it
should be  reduce it by about 10 percent
that means the consequence is we
are no longer allowed to build it is forbidden to
build says daniel in front of main of course
speculation is not my central
topic but demolition he says
forbid the demolition of buildings yes we
are not allowed to destroy them anymore we
have to use the resources  that are there
and we are no
longer allowed to build volkacher in the area but
we actually have to reduce sealed areas again,
especially traffic areas
and green them again and
we have to preserve the infrastructure that we
have this is a prefab building here
you would commonly say it is
with the West German  look at from
berlin let's say that  lots are
just being destroyed when the state of
berlin is leaving schools and of
course they are not
prefabricated buildings are incredibly usable skeleton buildings
we have to if we work on them
and dismantle them and then
preserve this infrastructure we
are not allowed to do what is there anymore
we have to think about new material cycles we have to
think about new material cycles here we are thinking of
waste wood so at the top of
this left diagram everything goes into the left diagram that there
are resources that go into the waste
area and everything goes out to the right
into the power plants because of course
the power plants do that as a lot  use we are
very happy to have this
cheap fuel
we have to completely
rethink the material cycle and maintain it in the construction sector because of
course at the moment we
release co2 again immediately
we have to direct all our energy in the
value chain towards the farmers
we are not allowed to burn wood anymore
we're not allowed to give papi any more wood
reap benefits the Federal Environment Agency
says we must have at least ten years of
use otherwise the wood will not have any effect on the
climate that means we must
store long-term co2 via wood in the construction
sector in the buildings two
examples very quickly this is an old
peat depot that has already had four lives
behind it  is 200 years old
already had several locations there should be
burned and we have
integrated a pure natural
cycle into the building as wood and clay. this
is of course a small project
, but it can definitely be
scaled up to the high-rise limit
if you  this way of thinking transfers
here we see this great life
forms surfaces grown nature that
means everything is reversibly reusable the way it was in 1850
before 1950
no one in germany would have
burned wood or thrown it away we have to go
back to such an
example here again the  ominous
prefabricated building in the case of a
ver  administration building from the zoo
it was about the energetic renovation
we stripped it, so to
speak, wrapped it in a wooden dress and preserved all the
resources
inside, i.e. old doors etc. found everything
worth preserving in exposed aggregate concrete, so we also wanted to keep all of these gypsum coffered ceilings at the
top and that  The important
thing is now here this is a life cycle assessment diagram of the vertical journey up here is the CO2
and there we see if we build a
replacement building so we see in the the
architects against constantly
tendering that such buildings are demolished
to make replacement buildings then this
large CO2 footprint would in  the outer ring is
created and because we built with the
wood we can compensate everything
else that we installed on windows etc.
in the co2 to virtually zero
and we saved 1000 tons of co2 on this
building the finished building
became a school project here in Gießen
competition entry not yet built
since h  But we have to keep the foundation in particular
for the
buildings that always eat up 30 to 40
percent of the resources because the whole
concrete forms the honorable famous component
that we have here here should have received the
new replacement building that
was reinforced a little and were then able to
the two-storey building
erected on top of it has therefore brought all the materials that
are built into the existing building back into the new
building and you can see
the beam up here the replacement new building
would conventionally emit two and a half thousand
tons of co2 and we have
a sink of two and a half
tons 2000 through the new building on the existing foundation  tons are generated so we
have a delta of 5,000 tons of co2 if
we use the right materials
or let's see what the forest
can do in the climate system yes we are
wearing says ernst ulrich von weizsäcker
and i think we actually have a
very positive
outlook outlook for the future  we are allowed to change a lot
se  we are exploring and inventing a lot of new
things and we should take that as an opportunity to look
to the future, many
thanks,
many thanks, mr. selection klinger, and
if you hear politicians say build build build soon after the
coalition negotiations in the federal government or in
berlin
, then
maybe we can see each other  the big gap
between the political debate
and what we could and should actually know politically is that you
just talked about the enemies of the
forest and the biggest and most dangerous
enemy of the forest is perhaps the
fire are forest
fires three years ago i woke up in the
north of  berlin in prenzlauer berg with
the smell of a
forest fire in your nose that was an
experience that got under your skin
i know how you experienced it
and someone who deals with the
consequences of this big fire in the south of
berlin in 2018 is dr kilo a
child  from the university of potsdam from the
institute for biochemistry and biology
and since then g  there is exactly
where this huge forest fire was the
project office for ohb so fire hammond
, this
research cooperation of eight
institutes
universities also addresses the
question of how we can actually
combine the forest conversion that is pending anyway
with the protection against
forest fires and
about it  please tell us thilo a child something now, thank
you very much
mr mohn for the nice
introduction and of course also many
thanks for the invitation here
that our research project
can imagine what is funded by
the forest climate fund, i.e.
ultimately by the federal ministry of
food and agriculture and  the
Federal Ministry for the Environment and
Nature Conservation and mr mohn have already
said it there are a total of eight
institutions involved almost all
from brandenburg the
university for sustainable development
in eberswalde is in charge and
the university of potsdam is also involved yes where
ic  h stop working
the project wants to research
climate residents but also fire-
resistant forests on forest fire
areas how they could look like
and how they can develop and
that is of great importance in our region
this is a map of the forest
fire risk or the forest fire risk index
and  there you can see on the left on the
left graphic of germany that the
region berlin-brandenburg stands out very strongly
red this is due
on the one hand to the dry climate and on the other hand
it is due to the high proportion of
pine forests which can
burn particularly easily and under  in most
climate scenarios if you look at the picture on the
right then with
climate change, i.e. a warmer climate
with not exactly increasing
precipitation, this forest
fire risk will also be taken
away, so a very, very important topic here with us
the main research areas are on
these forest fire areas in
faithful
brietzen just in the introduction  As has already been
mentioned, about 350 hectares of
forest were burned, some of which belong to the
city forest oftreuenbrietzen and some of which belong
to a forest owner
cooperative and these two owners
or groups of
owners who went different ways with the forest owner cooperative and
immediately cleared it
and in the treuenbrietzen city forest, a more differentiated approach was taken, in some cases
the stocks were left alone
but then treated differently,
we then had other forest
fire areas in there on the not far
away
troop training area in jüterbog, where
another 800 hectares burned in the early summer of the following year,
these are ours too
reference areas for natural
forest development
yes i would like to take you with me with some pictures
so that you have an idea of what it was like
here after the forest fire excep
here in november you can see all the trees
are dead all the ground veget
tion is burned and it is lead
only dead tree skeletons and ash on the
ground and some subsequently under
falling needles over
at the same time in
november the area of the forest owner coope
ative already looked like this, so here
he burnt wood was quickly compl
tely harvested and used and we have
big clear-cut
and then different
forest treatments started here we can see that
a treatment in the city forest
oftreuenbrietzen you can see a payment
so trees were planted the pines that were
still standing were
thinned out but a stock
was left
while of course it often
went differently with the forest owner cooperative
there we have picked areas
of pine trees sown but
other deciduous trees are also there and what you see here
mostly are zither
poplars or branches that have
already settled themselves in the following year yes
what are we investigating in our project
with the various working groups it
is  t an ecosystem research project in
which basically all relevant
components of these ecosystems are
examined and on the left you can see the
dead i.e. dead wood
other organic matter the soil the
inorganic components of course the
seepage water
microclimate plays a role and on the
right you can see the biotic
components i.e. the vegetation the  fungi the fauna
and
all these things
naturally influence each other and not, for
example, the dead wood will eventually go into
the soil nutrients, there
are carriers from the seepage water, the
microclimate is influenced, the soil
determines which vegetation
comes up, for which the microclimate is also
relevant  and finally
the vegetation then produces new
organic substance that is created, which of
course can also be decomposed
again and the same these interactions
as with the vegetation also exist
with fungi and the fauna and of
course all the biotis have  chen
components also interact
with each other
yes and now it is about what
the effect of forestry measures on
this ecosystem looks like and we
now have various treatments that
we can examine there so either
you do nothing at all or the residual
wood browns without what is
planted  or it was additionally
plowed or planted and
also additionally fenced off against wild browsing
and these different
treatments of course have
different effects of course
if you leave residual wood and trees there
then we have a lot of dead wood and
organic matter there and that becomes
the microclimate and the vegetation
influence and of course
the soil is influenced in the same way and thus the
nutrient supply and the microclimate
and in the end the big question is how
is the tree regeneration
going and above all we want to find out now in
this five-year period
how this is going in detail
has an effect yes and i would like to
end here with these pictures this is the trustenbrietzen city
forest
last year june 2020 and you can see
that a large,
far-reaching green has established itself there a
gigantic rejuvenation with zither
poplars but also with other
trees that can be seen there and  the
forest grows green all by itself
we already have the first results here,
just for the vegetation, first of all, that
should only show that, on the right are the
reference areas, the number of species on the
site that have been examined, so
biodiversity is first of all
promoted very decisively by this  a
forest fire that you might
not hear right now but like that and the
various existing treatments of
course also have different
effects
yes and that is my last picture that is
the condition on the clear-cut area in
September 2021 and you can see that the
poplars are now about four meters
some have become even higher
and g  anz by itself in contrast to
the many pine trees that were
planted, most of which have
died back, a forest has
developed here and I would like to
say at least that even under our
current conditions, we have
no risk that Brandenburg is now
hiding or something like that, it's just that
ask what will the forest of tomorrow
look like and here i would just
venture the prognosis that the stage here
already makes a big
contribution to bind carbon again right away
nutrients are to be bound and to build a new
ecosystem which will then
be treated in whatever way thank you
[  Applause]
Thank you very much Mr. Yes, we don't want to
go to the climatic forest in the forest tomorrow, he can also look
at it intreuenbrietzen or at jüterbog, we'll get to that in a moment and will go into more detail
later in the
podium round, but before that you can
now have a look  loosen up a bit
and you know auffri  now we are coming
to the second part of our chris and since
we are also talking about climate change
and climate protection here, there is
now a co2 question
that means another one before it was about
oxygen now it is about co2 and the
question is how many tons of co2 are  stored in
one hectare of forest in germany
i.e. 10,000 square meters how
much forest is there how much co2
stored if the forest grows 660
tons 30 or 40 tons of co2 can
you please choose one of the three options
and see how the answers
come in and i’ll see  times in the
audience, a number of you have ready
how big germany would have to be so that
the good 800 million tons of co2 that
emit annually through soil, forest and
agriculture could be bound
quite big bigger than the area
we have
20 times as big says mr baldamus and
that  is also one of the problems with
the many beautiful afforestation
announcements that we hear again and again
in de  r climate debate and
this time dear audience
you are not that well informed
the right answer at least 660 tons of
co2 a third knew so it
is not always worth deciding for the middle
ground next question which tree species is the
most common in the german forest and there you have
it right now  five
possible answers the pine the
lark with
the spruce the oak or beech
which ones do we have most often in all of
germany not in brandenburg but
in germany
and you can now decide
unite these
wonderful five trees
i hope you can visualize the silhouette of the
phenotype
i have  checked this morning
what spruce actually means in English
i don't know if you know it there are
always words that you always miss
when you get down to it spruce in
contrast too small but we are now
here in the german forest and spruce and
pine deliver each other  a race the
correct answer is the spruce
28  percent of the German forest are
spruce, the pine follows with 23 percent,
then comes the beech, the oak and the
birch make up another four percent and
then we have the last question and so let’s
go back here to the
bird room of the natural history museum which one
bird that's the question is also known as the
forest police the sparrow
ok rather seldom in the forest but still the
blackbird the woodpecker or the jay
and
you can
decide what actually does
a forest police do I'll ask
the audience here
ok so that  it's actually just a
popular term apparently
that's
where it comes from well and now
you should know who is this
noisy bird
and that's undoubtedly the jay
too dear audience you only
knew the right answer with a minority but at least woodpecker and
old here that was somehow
obvious it's the ark thank you very much
for taking part and  d you
should really take
part again right away if we
go onto the podium and discuss with each other
and i will introduce you and
then you can come on
stage gunnar one he has been the
head of the berliner forests since this year and we
have a preliminary talk  already
figured it out he's the area king in
berlin
because berlin is the metropolis in
europe with the largest forest area
largest forest owner anyway among
the cities in germany 30,000 hectares
belong to the almost belong to the
berlin forests
which are incidentally also outside
partly in bernburg to one  a good
part of the
berlin forests are certified by the forest stewardship council
for a piece of sustainability and the
fact that we also have these large forests
in the middle of the city that has
to do with history mr heine i
'm glad you're here take a seat
and we'll come  straight into the
discussion you are free to choose
the next one i would like to introduce
and there is the promised
bridge to the charité
is professor konrad august baldamus a
warm welcome, mr baldamus he
is actually a doctor by training
internal medicine nephrology that
is i think it is the kidneys if i
see it correctly but above all  he was
here today because he is the
chairman of the board of the august
beer foundation and anyone who deals a bit with
berlin forest history and the history of
science will
also come up with the name
august bier
he left a legacy in the
southeast of berlin the sauna faust where
attempts have been made for a good 100 years
soon to be remodeled they
guard and develop the legacy of
august beer nice that you are here and
as the third in the league i may
ask gentleman a chin on the stage and yes i
sit down
three people three gentlemen sorry that we
don't have any women they  one has been
ill and
yes, I'll just take over the pane now  l the
way i was put here we
are very qualified i think
and we want to look at the problem first of all
we have large areas of forest in berlin
and brandenburg
and we have climate change
i'll ask the group how it
actually looks like  how well are the
forests here in the region prepared for the
fact that we can expect
more extreme weather, i.e. heavier rainfall
less rain probable a
decrease in the amount of precipitation overall
at least a less favorable
distribution
and in particular rising temperatures
probably also longer-lasting heat and
periods of drought
yes how good are  the forests here are well prepared
i think this question is wrong
because none of us knows what the climate
will be like it will be warmer yes and
we have to prepare for a change
but we don’t even know
which forest which type of wood
has a climate at all  two to four
degrees more than 1900 and there
the mixed forest is of course the
first solution, but because it reduces the
risk
, because if i have six
different tree species,
i only have a sixth of the risk,
which initially breaks,
the question is really how can
we manage this with regard to the projected
climate change  changing the
appearance of the forest and also storing co2 at the same time
, because those are two
factors, the climate is changing
the most storing,
fast-growing and also co2-containing reservoirs
and on the other hand,
victims,
we don’t know that I’ll ask again
hahnheim because that's interesting,
the berlin forests are again quite
different from forests that are now heavily used commercially
, for example in the area of
y because we have had this forest protection for a long time, which
is also very
trong protection of drinking water in berlin, there has a
so been this forced forest conversion here for a relatively long time
look at
the climate  wandel as head of the berliner forests
already thought about it because we also
notice that our forest is causing problems with the climate
but you say it is absolutely
right it's something different if you
don't look at my brandenburg colleague
where the stocks are still
mostly monotonous and
we are really in the south of
brandenburg your dying off
phenomena with pine looks that
hurts
in the berlin forest it is also dying but
it is not that noticeable because the forest there is
also an oak
tree or there are also birch trees
or respectively in the second  tree
layer sometimes the laundry or the
linden tree
you have to look closely that you are pulling
you can see but also they say for the
non-foresters second tree layer a
second tree layer that's practically
how why under these
dominating spaces so you have around
obama  the pine or the oak then
grow, so they don't get that big,
so a boar  ash will
never reach 40 meters so that's it so
at 20 it's over or even the linden tree
well in isolation it can also be very
big but generally in the
forest it rarely gets that big i've seen a
specimen on the baltic sea that
's right  long but that's
the rare and because what you say is absolutely
correct the berlin forest naturally has a
different history so the forest
belongs to the city of berlin or the
berlin population you have to say yes
because you say it right it's a very
long time ago that resourceful  citizens of
berlin traded with the prussian state
and bought 10,000 hectares of forest
from the prussian state in 1915
and that was the basis for the
berlin forest areas, which were then increased in the
1930s,
where additional forest areas from former
estates were then bought, also for reasons of
sustainability  back then and
not only the wood sustainability
i.e. harvesting wood but the berliner
s  to provide the city population with food in a
sustainable way because the name of
rupprecht will perhaps be
known, who created a very modern
sewage system in berlin at the time and
just had the idea that what comes out at the back
can also come in from the beginning,
that means that he
turned the sugar substances on the sewage fields
and then reused these areas as fertilizer on
the city estates and just produced vegetables for the people of berlin that will
happen
at some point, of course, but
we don’t have to do that now, we all know that, but
we have already
addressed it with it, so it will be here soon, so
co2  sink wood producer but there is
also drinking water production and
recreation relaxation exactly
maybe it is less relaxing to
walk in the pine steppes serve in
the preparation i
read somewhere that four fifths of the forests in
brandenburg still consist of pure or
more or less rows of pine trees  nd
exist
i was a bit surprised because i grew up with environmental issues
at a time when people were talking about
acid rain and forest dieback in the
80s, even back then it
was a huge topic that you
actually want to get away from this
monoculture
that yes  then it also
causes the fire risks that you are dealing with now
how come that
apparently
more than 100 years of forest conversion in sows
or also in berlin since
large parts of the forests have
passed so completely without a trace yes so completely
without a trace of course not me  I think
you can already see certain successes,
but of course it takes time,
so even if it is done, then of
course I can’t do a forest conversion
in 10 or 20 years, but it’s
going to be several decades
before a new generation of trees comes
back in  the upper level has grown in
that you have to see first of all on the
other hand
you should always be
so make it clear the pine tree definitely has
its place here, even in the original
and natural vegetation, so we
shouldn't completely demonize it now,
but i think it will be more
about what mr
soon has to say in the future,
we don't know which one  forest which
tree species and which ones you also have to
consider the site conditions are
still different depending on what is
best and from my point of view you
can only say at the moment
to have as mixed forests as possible and different
options and then you will see
what might happen with them too  forest
fire areas that it happened the
way it did with this
massive rejuvenation of softwoods, so in
addition to zither poplar also birch and
so nobody
had predicted that,
although you might even have
known it but that’s
the müllroser e.g. that’s not the case at every
championship  in the neighborhood
but close enough that looks like the
n  natural succession has come and
that the aces are therefore primarily owned
and the citizens too and the pine trees
ultimately also that it is actually
clear that you don’t have to be
burned I’m just going to repeat what
the first reactions were, so to speak,
and where you said it  so
if we don't massively now and it was
an unbelievable pressure because it's also
in the
state forest law i think it says after 36 months it has to be forested
again and if it's not massively
reforested and so on then
none of that will happen that was like that
first assessment of many from the
frost area
we have seen there were different approaches
when dealing with the areas where there was a
fire,
so to speak the classic approach you
fly and plant or then check immediately
after you have cleaned everything up
or you leave it  another counter-example is
it in my words everything is like that
I also have the nice quote
here  colleagues found dead
pines are almost more valuable than
live ones it says in a
newspaper article that was your project i
assume there is quite a lot of tinder in there
also when dealing with these areas when
you then talk to
the owners who are concerned about costs and income  or
well, tell us a little bit about
it the problem is yes yes the problem
is of course the first
thing if the wood is not harvested, as in the examples in the city forest
, then of
course at least a small amount of
compensation for the
fire damage is lost because  that's the other
wood that was also sold,
albeit at bad prices, but
that's a point that has to be
taken into account, on the
other hand, it's always
a question of which measures are how expensive afterwards
and I think it's okay
In this project in particular, it's also very, very
exciting, although I'm a bit skeptical
, although it really is  after five years it can
already be judged which of these
measures will perhaps pay
off best in the end the stops that
have been made what you can definitely
say the effects on the ecosystem are of
course different and for
example there is of course the danger of clear-
cutting and
flights  over the whole area and initially
not having any
biomass on it on these
sandy soils,
many nutrients that are then in the
ash are washed out very quickly they go
into the groundwater that is a point and
they are lost in the ecosystem that may be
for some species at first  It can be exciting at times,
very poor locations, but when it comes to the
climate issue, that is of course
counterproductive and I hope that
we can get hold of all these components
and have reliable facts where
we can calculate them against each other
and we want to take
a look at them today
look at research
what i find interesting is you have
the auc  h i think it was
expressed that we are sometimes relatively
at a loss, so when asked
what the tree species in the forests look like
that we can still work with in 100
years,
there doesn't seem to be a lot of reliable
answers  is that because
the research is so bad or
because the problem is developing so rapidly
is a difficult question but i
would like to go back to the office
project which has a great
scientific claim so
i have not yet understood which
prostheses you actually use  set up and
also formulate definitively about the
statistical certainty with which
looking at the results appears at the
moment is more than an experiment
want to see what comes up yes and they
have the scientific approach
they don't have it at the time I gave a
methodical paper but the
scientific approach  and the contents of the
parameters the the
i would like to see a
clear i think i am i yes but
i am okay
we actually didn’t have any clear hypotheses
and we very bad because
i have that of course that of course has
to do with the application
for the overall only  I think there were two months
that was a call for
funding that came very suddenly but
that and fundamentally we can of
course not work
with similar
design experiments as, for example,
Mr. Forstreuter can, you can
control everything and
everyone from every treatment
the same number of trees and
mix them correctly and so on, of
course, with this as with many
projects that are running outside,
we have to use what is available outside and we also have
the scientific ability
and if I see the institutions
that way, a scientific
claim  provided we will
certainly also fulfill and we have
one  en we have
a total of new treatments and
on these treatments a
defined number of spaces then there is
still space like ip in
which further parameters are recorded
and so we actually have the
entire spectrum of different
treatments on the areas that are
otherwise  there is not much
difference locally there is a relatively
uniform landscape covered and
that is what will happen
under such conditions
mr hainer i would answer your question
again if you say where i
am unsure i would simply
say we live too short because
in forestry processes you simply have to reckon with
the periods of time that forestry
processes need to achieve he already said that
yes we can't
just flip a switch now and
say let's plant climate-resilient
welter and then tomorrow we'll be the
good guys that maybe someone can
gärtner can maybe do that
n goes out of it and says today it
's not raining yes it will be difficult for the farmer
he has to decide in winter winter
grain yes no how will the
summer be he doesn't know and i say we
foresters i have to honestly say we
make bets on the future we know
it doesn't we have to be honest we
don't know a lot of things i don't know
if my great, great grandchildren work with wood at all
i don't know what the
temperatures will be like let
alone the precipitation i
just don't know and that's why my
opinion is and it will actually come  also in
this project by leighton to
express that in the accompaniment of these
projects federally to be positioned
differently because that
gives the security there has to be
said yes even if i have five tree species
or six tree species you said then
maybe it’s just fine with me  a sixth
broken or two but I
still have something so that the federal government can be
set up that  i think it is
extremely important and i think that the
project in the treuenbrietzen forest
shows that very clearly because we
have to
remember we must not mix pears and apples of
course i can of course still sell this
burnt wood at an extremely
bad price
but what does the
wood harvest cost me what does the area
treatment cost me afterwards what does the
reforestation that dries up at least twice cost me
yes you have
to sum it all up and there is
another one it will always
refer to the forest law of
brandenburg there I was  20 years of forester
and it only says that cold
areas have to be reforested
who says that a burnt forest has been
felled bare it is still
stocked yes that the trees are no longer
growing that is also correct but that
is not in the forest  assuming that you
have to and in this respect i think the
head of state is loyal to  en brit had a
real thought that he
says moment i'll let it stand
why should i harvest wood with insane
costs which doesn't bring me anything
afterwards flights plant again
costs and costs costs so i think
you have to look at the total amount then
once at the expenses the  you
pushed ahead with the follow-up treatment of these areas
and there are definitely pioneers
i would say the hammer forestry district
southeast of berlin i know that my
ex-colleague tim defended a forest area of 35 hecta
es with teeth and ten fingers and d
d nothing but e
ery  year again and
this photo series it's unfortunately
not digital yet it's still analogue i
've been fighting with him for a long time that he digitizes it for me
that moves and that
's the prime
example fortreuenbrietzen
we don't have to do anything we don't have to be
afraid for the forest  it won't
perish we don't have a forest dying 20
at best we have a tree dying  en
individual tree species that are doing better and
worse but there will be a forest
it will look completely different
we will have to get used to pictures
that we cannot yet
describe even we
foresters it will be completely different but
there we have first  just and
maybe also science always i say
a paradox and a paradox to do
supposedly especially in berlin i
have had to lead many discussions
now when a machine
drives through the forest and trees are still
growing even though the sonatina looks like it is
an art  system and when you talk to
the population they all want
jungle and they think they have it in front of
the door yes but it has to be tidied up that's fine
we come to the population I want to talk
to the population yes we have them
too they hopefully will be watching us  and i would like to
remind you unfortunately we have this tool
the slip with the access number you
have to ha  use is in better hands than
me because it's lying there somewhere on
the floor but you can now
write your questions here maybe
there are already a few and I
'll try to use these
questions that I see here on the
screen to take them to Rheine
talked about science mr
baldamus i'll give you the
first word but let me ask you a question
you're both responsible for forest areas so you're also doing internships
what are your wishes or
demands from me for research
and perhaps also for
research policy, i.e. we  have a
very old forest university in eberswalde
here in the region but i hear now
there are many unanswered questions great
need for research is that enough of the capacities what can be researched there you have to be allowed
well i'm not a forest
researcher but i  think there are a
lot of questions and especially what you
asked which ba  um will he
maybe make it i think that an
assignment could be that the bicc the
climate
institute for
climate consequences and that that too so that it
can tell us very well what
kind of climate we have at the location that we are
now managing in a time iks  because sometimes
the 100 years tree lasts 100 years yes
and then you can also
tell you where is the climate now
what we can expect and we can
then see what is growing because I trees here
and then the conclusion let's see
our our many parks
that we have with all sorts of
exotic trees maybe
the tree we were aiming for grows
there and then you can take a look at the
tree in the park officials
look experimentally how can it look
here in the forest in the
world community  developing germany
i see you are a descendant of
august beer, who brought in such
unconventional approaches
with and this view of
the pa  rks that's an exciting thought
mr
heine so you looked a bit skeptical well i
don't exist no but i can't
do it because you said they are
fsc-certified the berlin forest
also comes with naturland so
doubly strict and we're going to be precise
with these so-called foreigners a bit
very critical about
i believe that this will change
sooner or later this very
close contact because the
development forces us to do it i would say quite
provocatively we can really afford what is
currently almost the most important tree species in
berlin forests like this  fighting how
we still do that is routine the
bird cherry yes so this secretly
with you it is very well able to develop
the traditional locations
to develop disturbed soils it
only has one disadvantage it is a light
tree species like our pine and grows
under  Of course, this one is not particularly
good, but neither does the oak,
if not the oak  e and pine don't
give light is the one that looks the same
without zero tina we wo
n't always say yes and what happened
we have a question from theodor right now
what measures are being taken to increase the
biodiversity of berlin's forests in
view of the increasing spread of
harmful invasive plant species
protect
be a clear question a wonderful vague
from the country no no it is not
agreed not at all but
i think you have a wrong
way of thinking
because the invasive plant species
are definitely
biodiversity additional organisms
additional structures so some
nature conservationists have also recognized that
even a pine forest  a
biodiversity has depending on how
different other tree species are
attributed that also fluctuates again
it's the difference and it
's an open secret that the
climax tree species climax forests beech i
just read it again in the holy halls
extremely species poor na  Mlich have
a very low biodiversity
and die that make the holy
halls they holy halls is a
thorn old in lübeck or that is in
mecklenburg western pomerania in the
feldberger lake landscape
a has not been managed for 300 years
350 years old not managed
or beech forest but by these  old
books that are really that old you
can still see a few copies the women
are all together and down they
have nothing else but the book under it
looks boring as [ __ ]
that means you can't put the question
in it you can't
know that i know from the  wrong thing going
out i want to control biodiversity by removing
individual species from this
biodiversity they are
also bio divers and now that goes exactly
in the direction of
fighting black cherry it is an incredible
effort and when i was not yet the head of
the berliner forsten but a  Buddy
had but for a long time Revierleit  he
is and i saw him always moving his
back how these
cherries are cleared i
asked him the question just for fun do
you also shoot all the birds dead
because it is enough a bird that finds a
practicing cherries nearby
the cherries deadline and then
with  lay it down again with the fertilizer package
it's pointless it's a fight against
windmill blades, although of course I
don't want to deny that we take away the bird cherry sometimes in
regeneration points where we are now
bringing in other tree species such as the corpse
and give them time to give the oak a
head start  yes but that the
two-dimensional thing that is still partly
done i think is wrong
yes please but you have to have seven
types of trees yes by that you mean in nature conservation for example the douglas fir or there was in the foreign before the ice age there was the douglas fir
here  yes some and other other tree species
that are now also among the useful
tree species include the auc  h are
economically well carried out they are
assessed as invasive and invasive is
not necessarily the same as harmful and
harmful is not necessarily in
wasilla they can do everything that has
already been said that they are harmful then they have
received this classification and you
have to but always in  individual case be very
careful the bird cherry is
a good example of the fact that it was a
species that was just
introduced and then became a big
problem that nobody
foresaw it and with which not only
the Berlin forests
have to struggle and  a 1 1 a pine forest with
a lot of wild cherries undergrowth is
not yet organically more diverse than the holy
halls so it is problematic
and we have to we have to do it
if so i don't want to absolutely
oppose the use of non-native
tree species but i think
you have to be very careful and with
many of them we know the risks
not yet they might grow
quite well at first and then
at some point the pest comes after
them that damages the stocks that has
n’t migrated with them yet and then you’re
surprised you’re surprised again so
it’s not all that easy either so what can
you do  take away in this topic
invasive species caution is
appropriate
and more careful experimenting and
documenting are also difficult maybe
I'll add to that I'm completely at
your side we should perhaps rather look at tree species that were well represented in the German forest in the olden days
,
if I mean I mean for example the  eibe,
yes, we have names, place names in the ore mountains,
all of which have
their roots in sport in eibenstock, why because it was there
and people used it and
unfortunately it has the characteristic that it is
growing damn slowly and we
have one after all, we have a concentration in
the germans  forests on the nuz
tree species that grow as fast as possible
because we  needed wood quickly 250
years ago the areas should be
planted so that wood grows quickly
the oak just didn't do that either
, it also takes 200 years to form
a reasonable trunk and or
the eleven would be the one you are at home in Germany
but look for it
please in the forest and various maples
and there are many tree species that we no longer have in
our tree species spectrum in the
users what they
are cared for yes and that's
actually what I mean I
don't really want to plant foreign countries now
and I  don't delete the
bird cherry either but i say we have
it here and we foresters brought it in
ourselves to improve the soil
conditions which also makes it excellent
because the leaves rot faster
and now we just have
to deal with it that that's mine  Appeal
who didn't have it, so I
called on them to participate, they're doing it too,
which is why I'm taking them now
let's get to the next question i
don't know if we can answer this here in cologne
i'll call you anyway from
charlotte to the construction lecture someone will come
in the round someone who deals with the
balance sheet of motorways the
background is the new construction of the
autobahn triangle the radio tower is located
after all took ohnewald  no,
charlotte can only say something about the outstanding blade,
insofar as charlotte
might ask someone outside of our
circle today to mr. roßwag klinger from the natural building lab at the tu berlin, please
tell me what your project is called
and now we come to a
question  which is then a little closer in the
forest by philipp why do people have
to take any measures at all in
the
forest in the forest nature does
n't adapt on its own here we are at
the
with the challenges the
different demands on
use and also anja balancing
the  somehow designing various ecological services of
the forests or  he
so why can't it be done easily or
is it like that so from the forest's point of view
it's definitely possible but that's the
question of what kind of demands we have on the
forest and then i'm happy to hand it over
i say i also say
you can't do that at all  problem we
can use the forest so it's not a forest in it is
actually a fund to be an
artificial system we don't have any
primeval forests in germany anymore you have to
be clear about that you also said something so
mockingly earlier about the people of Berlin and
their desire for primeval forest yes yes  yes
, you experience being in good hands again and again because we ca
n't clear away what's still
lying around
and now please imagine that
I have an artificial system where
even if it doesn't look like it,
an old one usually predominates I have
now means because of  1 90 or 100-year-old
pine population that is
n't doing so well climatically either and now tends
to make use of its end of life
and die off d
then it falls over as a whole and then i say
the bavarian forest has shown that where
our fellow bark beetle also
did a lot that there were really large
areas i imagine this
screaming in berlin if all the
pines in berlin fell down because we are
now  get another insect calamity
because an old one suddenly
dies and becomes susceptible to mass reproduction
of insects, which then of
course spread to the neighboring populations with
lots of fun and as an ssc-certified forestry we are not allowed to
use
any
toxins, so this is
really the very last resort and
you have to
I can't really imagine that with the people of Berlin I ca
n't really imagine
that being the first not
to keep your job up to date and to say people are like
that the natural or
biological processes have then
I can volunteer for tarring and
feathering so that's it
I didn't want to answer the question yet
because the ask  e is of
course generally the forest does not need the
people but we humans
need the earth from it from planet
earth we live from it and that's why
we use it we just
have to make it sustainable that there for
agriculture as well as for
forestry and and  not using the forest at all
would be stupid then we would
no longer have any wood to work with
would do something else that
is certainly not relevant to the climate
yes then due to the climate initially vaguely from
andy I would like to add a question from
myself or include it
if  we want to build with wood from brandenburg
are there
enough resources for that
maybe we'll stick with it for now
that's a question that's easy to answer
so the
forests of brandenburg and
berlin can build enough wood if the political motto is
now here with building in the region in the
future predominantly  or to rely exclusively
on wood as a building material
that depends on it i would yes because
if they turn i now assume
only constructive timber construction no that
may be the stocks are not suitable at all
and the pine also has
properties that are not
very easy in terms of construction like spruce and fir
so not that but if  we see more
constructively hard means so we thought of
the half-timbered house made of pine if we all want to move into half-timbered houses
and invent a technology
for building high-rise buildings made of half-timbered
houses the pine won't be enough for
that i think but there are also
wood-based materials than it will be  Kiefer
also processes e.g. USB boards or
chipboard or medium-density fibreboard,
so there are many
things you can do and of
course I can’t take stock of whether that’s
enough because I have to see we
all want to write something on paper
too  if we are very good with it
, but we
also need paper somewhere for the tap  floors on the
walls or many people just ca
n't dream of where there is wood everywhere
in which stories wood is
processed where it is processed
and then of course it becomes difficult
because if I only see one use that
doesn't go far enough for me I have to
Total and there I am again
, that in Germany we
also import masses of wood and and of
course you have to ask yourself the philosophical
question to what extent we
can afford to
no longer
manage and protect our German forest alone and
buy wood somewhere in africa or
south america that means the country
word is a clear year but yes the
parties to each other yes and probably
also to develop one or the other
so that the logistics and the
market processes work better
i think you have to go one step
further  we're going to use wood and
use it as a beam, possibly
or partially, it will be in the future  rt freshly
burned in energetically
used we have to drag it out
and find other products that we use
as a primary product eg what do
you do with it if we take the wood out of the building
how do we bring in the
next cascade stars cars cold stage
and  we have to
develop new materials and the longer we
will keep the material wood in the cycle
diversified as possible and
not use it energetically that is still
the last thing because we can
save fossil energy but the way to get
there has to be gone through a very complex
cascade of recyclable materials would be invented
yes  a huge field of work for the
technical universities in the region
i would now like to come back
to a statement i quoted at the beginning from this report by the advisory board for forest policy
it means
that the costs associated with forest conversion
also include the cost burden caused by climate change
actually no
longer financier  t can be achieved through the
income from the forest, which
comes almost exclusively from the sale of wood
, that is, if that is the case, then
the question is, do we need a new
economic system, new
streams of income for the forest owners,
and of course we are in an
incredibly exciting and difficult
political situation  Discussions one thinks with
horror of the subsidy in
agricultural policy and how it got completely out of
hand and now there are
calls for subsidies only if
owners
i ask around we are so
your views maybe it's
not about subsidies at all  but
if my view is actually a
very simple one we bind co2 in the wood and
every piece of wood harvested is
stored
co2 and we have to bring that into the long-established
supply chain and if we were to use
the co2 pricing of the wood
i would advocate that you
roughly  half to the forest owners
gives as economic  well the other the
other half but uses it to provide incentives
for the forest owner to rebuild
it further
none of us knows what that will be afterwards in
terms of co2 and climate relevance
what that stability what it is about climate
receptivity and
compatibility packs he was
the thing that you can do with the
other half of the co2 is that
we are a long way from it and of course there
are obama
plans
right now  to enable compensation regionally
why is the rainforest being
reforested in quotation marks to absorb the
consumption of berliners
why not do it in the region
we are actually correct in what you
suggested but he
wanted there must have also said how
many hectares of forest  we would need
to really compensate for that on the spot,
so we would have to do more in berlin  there are
several floors so that we can
win this place that doesn't work, yes, so
we have to make sure that
in the third world, too, we don't
check too far, especially in the amazon
and in the rainforest areas, and
then we have that as cellulose in our paper
, yes, that  isn't the problem yes as
cheap paper that comes with it also
contains fsc yes so with every toilet paper
they always have very fsc there are always a few
fibers there are fsc in there yes but you
have addressed a very, very old problem
the forester usually gets the wood
paid and that's the problem
because a good 100 years ago you could work
in forestry I have the problem
that because they came out of the felling just over 100 years
ago, you
always made nice clear-cutting
then reforested
this fell high forest and with this harvest  proceeds
from this wood they could easily
pay for the following culture and
could still properly  put money in
purposel that's no longer possible the
wood prices haven't
grown nearly as much as the expenditure has
grown they can carry on even if
these clear-cutting methods are high because
they wouldn't
even pay for the following culture for a long time, of
course they get money, that's the
duck  costs less there is still something
left but it's not even
really enough to reforest this area in a
qualified way but then that
's why we go to the other
services somehow yes exactly but like
when we say we want to
reward that, for example, that the forest
is CO2  binds how does
the co2 or the carbon content of the
forest get to the account of the old owner
when he pays where maybe that is
a challenge and an invitation to
the
social sciences in the region
to find answers no he was back
then they don’t need it but
they have CO2
taxes, they have the industry  e you
have the traffic you have the house the
houses those are the three big
co2 burn and the numbers the numbers in
a tool that will come on and from
this pool it doesn’t have to be a tax today
yes yes then it went somewhere
else but as than
extra account and that the duh account
you can effortlessly recover the co2
storage in the wood or also the
co2 storage in the earth i.e.
co2 from the air and
pump it in the cellars that won’t be
for nothing either so you can also use the
co2 storage  forest and wood pay yes
thank you very much mr baldamus for the
substantiation mr waiter from the
greens had complained that
the coalition negotiations are a
bit stalled at the moment also in terms of climate policy here
is a proposal that also fits in well
i think there is still a
lot to discuss
unfortunately we have to end this topic at this point
thank you all here in
the audience thank you at
home  se in front of the screen for being
there thanks also to the natural history
museum for being able to be here in this wonderful
space and to the
organization team for the balance 1 way that
was climate lab number three today at
the climate change center berlin
brandenburg i'm looking forward to seeing you
small  lab number four that will
take place in the coming year and in the
meantime i invite you to have a
look at the website of
the climate change center small with the name
climate change center there is also
a newsletter so you can stay up
to date and miss out  it's not
going to be back for the fourth
lab thank you so much thank you
[applause]